I do believe that there will be a future
where we find it weird that we used to
carry a flat screen in our pocket and
pull out this flat screen to look at it
in order to do our digital work I think
that some time soon when I refit my
office instead of setting up a bunch of
LCD panels I'll just put a large black
curved piece of plywood in front of me
and our we're at Hollins and all my
documents will appear in the real world
in front of me I absolutely believe that
the screen in the pocket or the screen
attached to the desk is going to be as
weird as the phone attached to the
building you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
you may not know who dr. Andrew
Fitzgibbon is but if you've watched a TV
show or movie in the last two decades
you've probably seen some of his work an
expert in 3d computer vision and
graphics and head of the new alt Data AI
group at Microsoft Research Cambridge
dr. Fitzgibbon was instrumental in the
development of Buju an Emmy
award-winning 3d camera tracker that
lets filmmakers placed virtual props
like the floating candles in Hogwarts
School for Witchcraft and Wizardry into
live-action footage but that was just
his warm-up act on today's podcast
dr. Fitzgibbon tells us what he's been
working on since the Emmys in 2002
including body and hand tracking for
powerhouse Microsoft technologies like
Kinect for Xbox 360 and hololens
explains how research on dolphins help
build mathematical models for the human
hand and reminds us once again but the
secret sauce to most innovation is often
just good old-fashioned hard work that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Andrew Fitzgibbon welcome to the podcast
hi Gretchen great to be here so I
usually start my podcasts by way of
introduction but I want to go a little
off script with you because you're funny
you've said that you situate your
research at the intersection of computer
vision and computer graphics with
excursions into neuroscience and at a
more subatomic level you characterize
your work as at its core extracting
information about the world from photons
so give us a little more context about
these excursions and extractions how in
general would you describe what you do
Andrew we'll get you up in the morning
so what I want to do is make computers
help us change the world and we can
change the world in a bunch of ways that
are useful to humans I'd like to think
that I work on the technologies that
underpin the ways we can make computers
make the world better for us a lot of
what we do in what we now call ai ai the
combination of machine learning computer
vision natural language processing it's
all about taking information from the
world and that information comes through
sensors somehow whether the sensors are
the pixels in a camera or the sensors in
a microphone or even the sensors in your
keyboard when you type a tweet these are
all sources of information from the real
world that we would like to do something
good with and for me something good
might be improving the computer graphics
in Harry Potter and I consider that good
because it makes lots of humans happy
and in some sense everything we do in
life is about making humans happy well
tell me a little more about the
excursions into neuroscience when you're
talking about computer vision and
computer graphics it might not seem a
natural leap but I think it kind of is
can you unpack that a little yes I
started collaborating when I was in
Oxford with some of the neuroscientists
who worked there and we were interested
in a fairly simple question which is
roughly can humans point at things now
you think obviously humans can point at
things
but we don't have a good theory for how
the brain integrates 3d information so I
was interested in purely providing the
neuroscientists with a sort of a
mathematical backup I was saying no one
thinks the brain does it by multiplying
matrices and vectors but if it did you
would see these sort of error patterns
and then we went to the real world and
looked at people wearing virtual reality
headsets and the kind of pointing
mistakes they make and those are
different from the patterns that a
computer would make using today's
technology so we still don't know what
the brain does but we have more evidence
that it's not the same as what the
computer does hmm all right so let's
talk a little more about extracting
information about the world from photons
that's a very granular way of describing
the computer vision work that you do
could you explain that technically a
little better so regular listeners to
your podcast will know that computer
vision is one of those problems that's
sort of easy to state you know does this
picture contain a cat or not but has
turned out to be incredibly hard and
even in this age of deep learning
successes with computer vision we still
know that it's incredibly hard
so my abstraction of gather information
from photons is just as kind of stand
back and say why are we so excited about
computer vision why are we so excited
about these capabilities and one of the
things that computer vision does is it
allows us to acquire information from
far away and of course one can hear
information from far away but it's a
capability that allows us to do things
like recognize people far away or to
drive a car and I want to think about it
at that level of abstraction because I
want to always understand that my end
goal is to do something real if we think
always about the end goal I think we do
a much better job of making progress on
the fundamental research the alternative
is to say my interest is in
understanding deep neural networks I
absolutely love trying to understand
deeper
that works and I do so as a theoretical
level but also I want to know what the
practical consequences understanding
will be well now that we've situated
your research
let's situate you until this week I
would have introduced you as a partner
scientist in hololens but you've
recently been tapped to lead a group at
MSR Cambridge called all data AI or ADA
which turns out to be an acronym that
references Ada Lovelace was that
intentional at all and why if it was so
yes it was intentional in the sense that
Ada Lovelace is sometimes considered the
world's first computer programmer
whether or not she programmed computers
she certainly was the first person to
observe that the computational powers of
the analytical engine or the difference
engine could be applied to quantities
that were not numbers now of course
since the dawn of computers we've
represented quantities in the computer
like strings of characters like words
they're all numbers so what's new about
saying that it operates on something
beyond numbers well the thing that's new
is not so much that the computer
understands the sequence of numbers but
that it can understand the
interconnections between them and that
is represented fundamentally by a
computer science concept called a graph
and a graph is something that we can use
to represent a wide variety of computer
science concepts ok so why now with this
group at MSR Cambridge has there been a
confluence of things that exist now that
didn't before I think of course we have
all observed the advances in AI due to
the advances in machine learning due to
the advances in deep learning and I
think now as a golden opportunity to
apply that to a broader range of areas
it's also a fantastic opportunity here
and now for us to think about a new
generation of AI programming until today
AI programming has been the domain of
high priests and priestesses
who have PhDs in machine learning or and
you understand linear algebra and yet we
believe that actually a lot of AI
programming could be a lot simpler so
we're looking at how we might think
about a third generation of AI
programming the first generation would
have been they raw work of Hinton and
Lacan who just wrote the code you know
it was difficult code to write the
second generation is this set of tools
which go by the name of tensor flow and
PI torch again which lots of listeners
will have used or heard of and these
tools have been again fantastic for
democratizing AI but they make it hard
for somebody who's just a great computer
programmer to understand and to in my
view they somewhat hides the beauty of
the AI models the rods beneath neural
network models are actually relatively
simple they're simple models with
complex consequences and the research
world is increasing its understanding of
these complex consequences but it's also
nice to just see the code unadorned and
see how simple these models are
[Music]
well let's go back aways before we talk
about more current research because you
have some what I would call greatest
hits in your earlier work one is called
buzu a camera tracker that actually won
an Emmy and it's been used in computer
graphics and live action footage and
what I've heard is pretty much every
movie made since it was released in 2002
tell us more about Buju how and where
did it come about what does it do and
how does it work technically
Buju was a great fun project I moved
from the University of Edinburgh where I
did my PhD to Oxford University in the
mid 90s and I was working there with
some amazing people who were interested
in the question of how a robot might
navigate its way around some building or
around some environment so we worked
hard on the how does a robot navigate
problem and we discovered that one of
the things the robot has to do in order
to know where it's being in three
dimensions is to build a
three-dimensional model of the world and
we worked hard on making a beautiful 3d
model because we figured this would be
useful maybe for those industries where
even today it's common for example to
sculpt a car out of clay before building
the computer model certainly in those
days if you were going to have an alien
in the movie I think pitch black was one
of the first aliens we looked at they
would make the alien out of clay and
then try to scan it into the computer so
we thought we had a great product we
were gonna use our robot navigator spin
the camera around the alien model pull
that into the computer and then give
people a computer model of the 3d object
it turned out nobody in the movie
industry was interested dang it you had
to yeah yeah you had to spray paint the
model with a toothbrush to get texture
on it it didn't work in little corners
it was terrible and they could just do
better by using you know existing
artists to create the models but
somebody at one of the effects companies
kind of thought through how we must be
getting this model and said how do you
know where the cameras are we said you
know well it works it out
that's part of how we get the 3d model
we work out how the cameras are so turns
out something you really need in movies
that's really hard to do is to figure
out where the cameras are now what does
that mean that means maybe I have a
camera mounted in a boat and the boat
contains some hobbits and is sailing
down a river towards you know some
impressive mountain it would be just
great if the impressive mountain had two
huge statues pointing at the hobbits but
it turns out that nobody built those
400-meter statues so what we have to do
is build some statues back in the studio
and we built some 40 centimeter statues
back in the studio and if only we knew
what motion the camera had undergone
while it rocked in that boat moving down
the river we'd be able to make a robot
do the same motion and then we could
superimpose the the images so in those
days the only way to find out where the
camera was was you could imagine trying
to use markers or trying to use GPS none
of these things work so you would have
to just sort of manually position the
camera for every single shot it was
incredibly expensive so somebody who had
worked on that kind of footage realized
that our algorithms were producing this
as a kind of an unwanted side effect we
flipped
I guess nowadays we would say we pivoted
a start-up and Buju was launched and I'm
super proud of it because it was one of
the first products which did kind of 3d
computer vision there were products
available then that would do character
recognition that would do number plate
recognition but this really did 3d
vision and we had to go beyond the
academic state-of-the-art to deliver it
and we learned about delivering computer
vision to the real world some of what we
learned was you just have to type in
lots of code people would ask me you
know what's the secret sauce and buzu
and I'd say well you know have you read
all the papers on 3d structure of motion
they would say yeah I'm pretty sure of
them I would say yeah that's the secret
sauce we implemented all of them you
know it's an attitude that helps us
today sometimes in research you're
assessed by how beautiful and clean your
algorithm is sometimes in the real world
you have to implement all the dirty
algorithms until you find a beautiful
one
but with buzu it just work to me and
something that was actually useful you
know on that note I was gonna ask you a
question further down in the podcast but
I'm gonna bump it up because it's sort
of tied in I imagine you said it about
this you once said if I had to nominate
one key to success that's a focus on
everything so what you're talking about
that's exactly what I'm talking about
yeah exactly there is no silver bullet
you know you really have to focus on
building a real thing and that just
means something that other humans would
be happy to use so remember in Buju we
didn't focus on the right thing but the
real thing we wanted to build was this
3d modeler and we knew we would make a
sort of a what's called a Wizard of Oz
demo we'd say if this thing worked it
would make you a model that looks like
this would you like it and then when the
humans agree that's that's what they
would like then you have a target and
then of course you may have to pivot or
you may deliver something that's only
half as good and discovered that hey
that's still useful or you may achieve
everything you thought you needed to
achieve and discover that actually it
needs to be twice as good but I really
like having a concrete goal to aim for
well that's a beautiful segue into the
next topic I want to talk about because
Microsoft's Kinect technology has been
dubbed a failure that became a great
success and the science behind it has a
fascinating history you were there early
on and I'd love you to share some
stories about connect with us what's
your particular perspective on this
technology how did it come about how is
it evolved and how has it impacted other
areas of research you're involved in I
love the Kinect story because in some
sense it's a classic example of when
academic style researchers meet
engineers who really want to change the
world
so at Microsoft Research we were looking
at whether we could make computer vision
algorithms that would be able to follow
the movements of the human body and we
were working with the academic research
field and we were doing pretty well and
we had good results so one day the Xbox
people Alex kipman who is working in
Xbox then came to us and said we've had
this great idea for
video game where you're gonna like
recognize the motion of a human in a
camera and then it's gonna control the
games and it's going to be amazing and
we said I'm glad you asked us that
because we're actually the world experts
on this and I can tell you it's not
gonna work so then they said oh yes when
you say that cuz look at this program we
wrote and they showed us their version
of it and their version was better than
anything in the academic literature oh
my gosh
some genius programmers had put together
an amazing demo of how it would work
what was amazing was is was using an
idea from the academic literature but
they had engineered it so well and made
it so effective and really worked hard
on it
mm-hmm the reason that idea wasn't very
popular with academics at the time was
this it's pretty hard to take a single
image from a camera identify the human
in the image and then list off where the
hands are where the elbows are but
supposing you already had an image from
let's say 30 milliseconds ago because
it's a video sequence and you already
knew in the image from 30 milliseconds
ago where everything was then you could
just simply say to yourself well they
can't have gone far they were there
effective milliseconds ago you know and
find where everything was so we knew how
to do that in academia but what no one
had done has really really worked hard
on that really kind of tried to moon
shot that and make it really work and
our contribution was to observe that
okay you've got a system that works 99%
of the time assuming it was right 30
milliseconds ago there's a calculation
you can do which tells you that system
will definitely fail after five minutes
and this is what they observed and they
knew that that would happen and you
could design it gain around that that
you know ran in sort of three minute
sections and then reset itself but
ideally you would have the system just
not make mistakes like that
so our first contribution was to say
what we need to do here is just
basically have the system every couple
of seconds kind of reset itself and we
were using machine learning and this was
kind of an early instance of machine
learning really being applied to one of
these hard computer vision problems so
we said to them okay we could maybe do
it maybe but you know we would need
real-world examples of this thing
running
in ten different living rooms across the
planet in order to even know if we're
doing well not to mind trainer machine
learning algorithm and then the
horrifying moment two weeks later when
we're out of coal and they said yep
we've got ten people in living rooms
across the planet or Japan people are
finishing up there tomorrow and then
they're moving over to China and so
suddenly we realize okay these people
are really serious and then when we
needed to hire a Hollywood studio to
generate training data they hired a
Hollywood studio to generate training
data so there was just a huge amount of
vision there which we were saying this
stuff cuz it seemed bright but really no
one had done it to that level before and
the reason was they understood what the
machine learning was doing they figured
it works from examples if you don't have
enough examples no-brainer let's get the
examples first academics would always be
unhappy spend a year building a better
theory whereas with connect the
partnership with people who really want
you to get stuff done maybe that's where
ever inherited some of this allowed us
to make really fantastic progress
[Music]
[Applause]
microsoft's hololens is another computer
vision technology that you've had a lot
to do with so give us the Andrew
Fitzgibbon take on hololens and its
journey from birth until now with the
release of hololens - what have you
discovered about its capabilities over
the years and what do you think hololens
has contributed to the computer vision
research community hololens is an
amazing device it came out of the same
team that we worked with on Kinect Alex
kipman steam and at one level hololens
is exactly what kipman said it was when
they announced it first three maybe four
years ago he said this is the future of
the PC and in one sense I do believe
that there will be a future where we
find it weird that we used to carry a
flat screen in our pocket and pull out
this flat screen to look at it in order
to do our digital work I think that some
time soon when I refit my office instead
of setting up a bunch of LCD panels I'll
just put a large black curved piece of
plywood in front of me and our we're a
holland's and all my documents will
appear in the real world in front of me
I absolutely believe that the screen in
the pocket or the screen attached to the
desk is going to be as weird as the
phone attached to the building so that's
far future that's when hololens has the
form factor of a smallest of the set of
glasses but towards that future hololens
today is amazingly valuable for real
people doing real work because hololens
lives in the 3d world it has lots of 3d
vision in it one of the pieces that I'm
incredibly impressed by in hololens
because i didn't work on it does the job
of figuring out where your head is in
the 3d world this is related to work I
did you know on bushu many years ago but
on hololens it does it all the time in
real time on an incredibly low powered
device so that's a beautiful piece of
technology that again
I think very few people other than
Microsoft could have put together my
work on hololens sent from a piece of
very blue skies research we did almost
ten years ago now we that me and a
friend called Tom Cashman who arrived as
an intern we decided we want to learn
about the 3d structure of stuff that
moves
what stuff that moves well the human
body is something that moves and we knew
a bit about the 3d structure of the
human body from Kinect but we wanted to
learn about this 3d structure just from
still images so we had to think of
something that's kind of bendy and movie
but that is somehow not too bendy and
not too movie so who we realized that
dolphins were the ideal thing to work on
so we decided to write a paper called
what shape are dolphins now we didn't
really care about dolphins but we cared
about bendy movie 3d stuff and we worked
on that paper in order to build
mathematical models of 3d we thought
well why did we want to know about 3d
well when you're interacting with the
virtual world or the mixed reality world
in the hololens one of the important 3d
objects is the human hand if the system
can look at your hands and fully
accurately determine the position of
every own and knuckle in the hand then
you can use your hands in the virtual
world to pick up virtual objects and the
virtual objects behave exactly as you
would expect from real world physics so
the research on dolphins became a
research on the slightly more bendy
object that is the human hand and then
we knew that this technology was useful
for something hololens was being
developed so we thought let's see if we
can deliver this dream of real world
physics to the hololens and we were
extremely happy to see announced
recently a Mobile World Congress in
Barcelona hololens - with fully
articulated hand tracking let's shift
over and talk about ada a little bit
more deeply and talk about specific
problems you want to tackle and what
technical ground you hope to break in
the projects you want to take on what's
on your roadmap Andrew so ada
is about permeating AI into the parts of
the world where we almost don't yet know
we need it today we still can't ask
questions of the internet like find me
all the ski chalets within a hundred
meters of the slopes right that's a hard
question why is it a hard question
because all the ski chalets have their
own little website it's not necessarily
aggregated and the way to answer that
question is very easy you should just
read and understand all the web pages in
the world and be able to answer any
questions about them so a computer that
can really read and understand all the
web pages in the world it's clearly in
some sense you know sort of infinitely
far away so the idea is that throughout
computer science there are areas where
we can permeate using AI in machine
learning to deliver systems that work
better so for example on the hololens we
had to take our hand tracking code which
we wrote as standard you know computer
vision researcher code and make it maybe
500 times more efficient in order to run
on that low power device now if we could
achieve that for general code then maybe
we could make you know 500 times more
efficient the the code we run in data
centers around the world maybe we could
achieve 500 times as much and we could
save energy
if we had capabilities in user
interfaces that allowed us to adapt so
that what the user is doing but not be
annoying this is a crucial combination
then of course we would have much better
capabilities of course we would have
happier users happier humans if we think
about the challenge of maybe adapting
user interfaces so that my user
interface works better for me and yours
works better for you one of the things
that we want to do is learn from a very
small number of signals so maybe every
time you switch on your computer you
know you arrange the windows in a
certain order we already have systems
that will try to learn your preferences
and try to
do that for you but what we know today
is this a lot of the times the systems
that do that are a bit annoying
why are they a bit annoying because they
don't have the human level understanding
or this person's at hurry this person's
using a different machine they're in a
different context they're at home not
work how could a system really
understand from small amounts of
training data what it should do and when
it should do nothing and these are areas
which I think we're sort of touching on
today there are whole areas of AI
research that our team looks at and
there are different questions in all of
them again there's this trade-off
between a fundamental research angle and
how we actually going to demonstrate our
AI to the world
[Music]
so Andrew I've heard you use the phrase
change the world or a better world and
these are the sort of end goals so there
are a lot of things that could go right
if you're successful do we have to talk
at least a little bit about what could
possibly go wrong
so with all of the possibilities that
you're describing they seem to pose new
kinds of social protocols that we'll
have to develop and adapt with things
like advanced 3d computer vision and
head-mounted computers and cameras
galore is there anything that keeps you
up at night
there are things where I think I have
some idea what the answer is gonna be
and then there are things where I hope I
have some idea what the answer is going
to be let me do one of the first ones
when I describe a world where
everybody's glasses have the possibility
of projecting 3d content into the world
in front of them you can immediately
think but this is terrible people are
going to just either spend their entire
time looking at the content and not
interacting with the other person in
front of them but I think we already
have social protocols that solve that
today so if you and I are talking and
there's a TV over to the right maybe
I'll turn to look at the TV it's rude
but maybe you understand something
interesting must have happened on the TV
and we both turn and maybe it's
something we'll discuss and we get back
to chatting we also have soda protocols
it's rude for me to take out my phone
and look at it when I'm talking with you
but you understand if I tell you well
I'm just gonna look that up or I'm just
gonna figure out what's happening that
meeting so I'm not worried
with something like hololens that we
won't easily develop these protocols we
might need some technical solutions like
when there's something in my 3d world
maybe is you know my email clients is
maybe sitting on the desk in front of me
you can see that it's my email client
but of course you can't read the content
within it so but these are technical
problems we can solve the social
protocols I'm confident there we will
develop and I'm not concerned about that
aspect but you might well say okay but
you should be concerned about maybe a
world where the cameras on my device are
revealing information that I wouldn't
revealed to other people in the world
and I'm happy that we the AI community
essentially are talking about this and
thinking about ways in which we can
ensure the security of our data so that
any person can have a concrete
understanding about what information is
leaving the device how well encrypted
information is used and that we can all
have protocols for how we dispose of
information when we don't need it
another exciting thing about the
hololens is that for example in hand
tracking none of the images that the
cameras take leave the device and today
we are looking at a number of ways in
which i can securely send your
information to the cloud securely do
machine learning on it and send the
answer back and then delete the
information and guarantee that to the
customers so that's one aspect where we
as Microsoft have just devoted an awful
lot of effort to thinking about security
and privacy of that information another
side of security is trust we earned that
trust
obviously by you know having behaved
well in the past by having strong
statements about what we're gonna keep
and what we're not going to keep and
also by the strength of our research in
aspects like secure computation and
secure machine learning it's story time
and you've got a good one tell us what
got a young Andrew Fitzgibbon interested
in computer science and what was your
path to Microsoft Research gosh it's a
long one I grew up in the 80s I liked
mathematics
I liked messing around with electronics
because we didn't really have computers
then we had computers at school one of
my summer jobs was as a water taxi
driver and being a water taxi driver
means you're incredibly busy from about
9:00 a.m. to 11:00 a.m. when all the
boats go out to the sea and then you're
incredibly busy from about 3:00 p.m. to
about 6:00 p.m. or maybe 7:00 where
everyone comes back so you've got a huge
amount of time sitting out in the Sun or
maybe the rain during the day where
you're just kind of killing time and one
of the things you can do is read and of
course if many of your listeners will
love mathematics you can play around
with mathematics
but what was also great back then was
because you didn't have a computer
beside you I would write program so that
I would then try and type in the
following day when I got to school and
that was just a great way to code in a
very casual way learn about computer
programming assignment scratch out of a
program a paper line ten do this line 20
do that or later I would write an
assembly language the little bits that
needed doing and it's kind of
therapeutic it's like solving
mathematical puzzles write mathematical
puzzles are great but they're hard to
invent for yourself so you might buy a
book of mathematical puzzles and then
you solve them all after a few weeks
whereas with a computer program your
course continually inventing the puzzles
for yourself right so from that job as a
water taxi driver then what then where
so I did mathematics and computer
science at University I wanted to do
physics but the physics department told
me it would be much too hard to do
physics with computer science and
someone told me later that also they
weren't that keen on people with blue
hair so I ended up doing mathematics in
computer science the mathematics
department were much more enlightened
and I was sitting in a topology lecture
one day and thinking what would this
stuff be useful for and I thought oh
maybe it'll be useful for recognizing
the shapes of letters and basically I
went and found myself a master's course
that had something to do with computer
vision and I went to heriot-watt
University in Edinburgh which was
running a fantastic course on sort of
they called it knowledge based systems
nowadays you would think of it as an
introductory AI course so I finished my
Master's and then I got a job as a
programmer in Edinburgh University I got
that job in 1989 but then somehow by
1997 somewhat accidentally I ended up
with a PhD I remember now how that
happened I was sitting in some meeting
as the programmer and they were talking
about their research and I said
something like well has anybody tried
just like rendering 500 views of the
thing and then using that and someone
said oh you should write a paper on that
and I thought it was a joke and of
course it turned out that that was my
first paper it was one of these things
where let's use brute force instead of
mathematics and see what happens and
from then on
you know I hope I've managed to do
elegant mathematics as well as brute
force but I think the practical mindset
was there even from then well sometimes
you need tweezers and sometimes you need
a hammer right exactly exactly
all right so was that your accidental
PhD and then what
so the PhD was part-time with a research
assistant job at Edinburgh and that job
was coming to an end or at least I
thought it was coming to an end because
the contract was due to end at a certain
date and of course like a very clever
person I forgot to ask anybody whether
that was true so I started looking for
another job I ended up in Oxford working
with the great computer vision
researcher of the UK andrew zisserman
and a bunch of other amazing people and
there again I learned the interaction of
mathematics and code
I worked there that led to Buju which we
have mentioned earlier and then about
mid 2000s I moved to Microsoft research
right you did a bit of a drive-by on
reference to blue hair it was the 80s
but did you indeed have blue hair oh yes
I indeed had blue hair for much of my
undergraduate career it was varying
degrees of blue and then sometimes we
could turn into green when the bleach
wore out was it ever Smurf blue no it
was kind of a dark electric blue at
least that was the aim well at the end
of every podcast I give my guests a
chance to say anything they want to our
listeners and sometimes it's general
advice or wisdom or inspiration other
times it's specific challenges or open
problems in the field so what would you
like to say to emerging researchers
people sometimes ask what problem should
I research and you know there's a sort
of a simple general answer solve
important problems that will change the
world but sometimes that's too big and
you don't really have an idea what the
big important problems are a signal that
I found valuable is when you're
listening to a talk or reading a paper
find something that annoys you find
something where you think really that
can't be the right way to do this
then and this is crucial ask yourself
really why is this annoying me and then
find a real-world example where the
thing that's annoying you is going to go
wrong a real-world example just needs to
be something that you know we should be
able to do none of the existing
technologies can do it and you've got an
idea and I think that has been a very
valuable source of inspiration for the
times when you don't have a big idea
sometimes you just have a big idea and
that's great go for it and don't forget
to focus on everything focus on
everything
Andrew Fitzgibbon thank you for joining
us from Cambridge today thank you it's
an honor to have being here
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Andrew
Fitzgibbon and the latest in 3d computer
vision and all data AI visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]